[Musique]
salut tout le monde alors on va regarder
une partie qui s'est jouée lors d'un des
derniers title tuesday et qui a opposé à
l'ex enhco joueurs présents aux
candidats à hikaru nakamura que vous
connaissez probablement tous je vous
rappelle que la cadence cdu 3 + 1 et on
va notamment regarder cette partie parce
que c'est une scandinave sympa et je
vais pouvoir vous expliquer quelques
petites choses thématiques dont que
quatre des cinq qui comprend des cinq
d'un prend des cinq cavaliers ces trois
grandes variantes attaque la dame et
hikaru qui va jouer la variante
classique damas un qui est aussi le
ku'damm des six aujourd'hui qui
théoriquement est intéressant et pour
ceux qui veulent éviter un maximum de
théories d'amd 8 qui laisse un petit
avantage aux blancs mais peut être
jouable surtout à un faible niveau
donc damas cinq jouer davantage c'est
que ça va créer un clouage sur le
cavalier d4 et hikaru qui joue
immédiatement c6 r - je vous plutôt
cavalière 6 à l'ancienne il joue ses six
qui de toute façon et un coût important
dans la plupart des variantes puisque
quand le fou va arriver en d2 et le et
l'autre fou ans et quatre cavaliers des
5 sera une menace pour enfermer la dame
et on aura une casse de retrait ce qu'on
va voir ensemble donc cavalier f3 fouet
f5 fous ces 4 e 6 etf ou des deux par
interversion de coûts il rentre dans les
grandes variantes à l'ancienne que je
connais ici on joue plutôt cavaliers f6
dans ce que je connais alors après
cavaliers apsys le la grande variante
yade à me2 qui est possible ça re
transposera à la grande variante ses
cavaliers des cinq attaques la dame
comme je vous disais le pouce et si ça a
été primordiale puisqu'il permet d'avoir
la case des huit pour revenir et ici
après cavaliers pro f 6 échecs les noirs
ont deux choix d'un prince is who gets
prend m6 et les deux variantes doivent
donner un petit avantage aux blancs
après fou d2 il joue cavalier 17 et là
dessus de moi de ce que je savais c'est
que le problème c'était des cinq ici et
le truc c'est qu'après dame c5 qui est
le coup qu'on joue normalement si on met
le cavaliere même si ce jeu vous
remettre
et là il ya des princes et des
princesses qui attaquent le carrier 17
et c'est toute la différence
lorsqu'on a le cavalier en effet 6
c'est que
après des cinq dames c5 on attaque le
fou mais il n'y a pas de déprendre 6
puisque on jouera dame prend ses 4 et
donc l'idée des noirs c'est que au
prochain on veut jouer tout bêtement
s'éprend des 5 et gagnez un pion alors
le truc c'est qu'après cas et 17 des
cinq du coût à anjou padam c5 à cause de
desproges 6 comme je viens de vous
l'expliquer donc on prend le pion des 5
et les blancs qui peuvent jouer cavalier
prend des cinq donc ils profitent de la
découverte sur la dame et après dame ces
cinq attaques
le fou et menace le cavalier il y as
dame eux deux et d'après ce que je
savais c'est censé être un petit
avantage blanc même un avantage correct
après tour ses huit four b3 parce que
les blancs les noirs ont du mal à
terminer leur développement les pièces
sont pas développés et les blancs vont
avoir du jeu notamment sur le roi au
centre est un jeu de pièces actifs avec
des fous des quatre pour gagner des
tempos sur la d'amd qui avait lieu trois
reculs qui regagne des tempos sur le fou
et ça se passe plutôt bien
cependant après fou des deux cavaliers
alex enhco qui joue dame de fou b4 pour
éviter les découvertes à trois cavaliers
gf 6 et grand roque donc ça rentre dans
une variante ont fait cavaliers f6 dame
de fougue et 4 à 3 ou rock cavaliers b17
et grand roque et donc on a on a cette
position de manière théorique heure là
c'est lorsque j'ai vu car ou hésiter une
petite seconde à jouer
fou prend à trois qui marche pas du tout
alors pas à cause de mes prend à 3 qui
est une erreur qu'on va déjà jouer des
fois je le tente en blitz que sur b
prend à 3 il ya dame prend à trois
échecs roi b1 et b52 qui est pénible
le truc c'est qu'on peut pas mettre le
fou en b3 qui protégerait troupes tout
bien à cause de dame prend b3 et on joue
sur le clouage du pion ces deux donc il
faut continuer par fou d3 d4 et sajoo 1
mais les noirs ont une attaque assez
sympa à jouer mais le truc c'est que sur
ce fou prend à 3 il ya le petit cavalier
des cinq intermédiaires qui est très
pénible attaque la dame avant de manger
le fou on va dire que la dame reste au
contact du fou pour pouvoir rpt manger
mais après faut b3
du noir se retrouve très mal si vous
voulez tenter ce genre de sacrifice à
base d'oeuf ou prend à 3 ici il faut
commencer par b5
mais théoriquement c'est pas très bon
non plus mais voilà si vous voulez
tenter un truc un peu marrant faut
commencer par b5 et après je vous le fou
prend à 3 mais vous allez si votre
adversaire connais vous allez quand même
perdre ya je crois qu'il marque vraiment
marrante aussi avec un cavalier six
dames un échec
il peut y avoir des trucs un peu marrant
mais faut savoir que ça marche pas donc
après grand roque hikaru qui a fait
[ __ ] en c3 ces grands coups francs ces
trois dames c7 et roye b 1
et ici il a décidé de jouer avec grand
roque alors normalement de ce que
j'avais appris ici c'était b 5 fu b 3 à
5 donc on veut se servir de ce plan à
trois pour attaquer allèles dames et on
va jouer avec petit rock ça va être
dangereux on va se prendre la marée de
pions aussi mais on veut jouer sur la
force de ce fleuve 5 qui tape dans le
rock et du pion à 3 donc il va nous
permettre de faire une rupture rapide
sur l'ale dame ou sajoo c'est compliqué
dans la partie joue grand roque plus
tranquille mais le truc c'est que on
utilise pas un peu ce cette concession
qui a été fait par les blancs et la
vitesse d'attaqué qu'on peut avoir et on
va se retrouver simplement avec un petit
désavantage parce que les blancs on la
perd de fou dans la partie va jouer tout
rachat avec les blancs cavaliers des
cinq donc thématiques et environs des
cinq ans ayant un f4 fou des deux rois
b8 on se barre avec le roi sur une
meilleure case h3 pour préparer
éventuellement g4 h6 se donnent des
cases de repli au foufou b3 pourquoi pas
prophylactique cavaliers f4 attaque la
dame dame f1 protège le pion et enlève
la dame g5 prend de l'espace à l'endroit
est ici il aurait dû jouer avec les
blancs un coup comme g4 pour s'en
prendre aux fonds ftq qui doit partir et
maintenant h4 qui met la pression sur le
pion angers 5 et donc quelque part aussi
sur le cavalier f4 pour le déstabiliser
et avec cette prise d' espaces allaient
droit les blancs auraient pris un petit
avantage aurait conservé leur petit
avantage parce qu'après g5 qui va jouer
fou c'est un qui est un coup assez
logique ça permet de
de faire parler les tours sur les
colonnes ouvertes notamment la cour d un
manant qui n'est plus bloquée par le fou
mais hikaru qui utilise un plan
thématique dans ses positions il fait
fou j'ai 6 h 4 donc avec cette idée de
s'en prendre option g5 et de
déstabiliser déstabilisé par dont la roi
mais fou h5 contre attaque sur le
cavalier f3 qui est cloué ne peut pas
bouger et après âgées fou prend f3
j'éprouve 3h pranger 5 avec ce petit
plan fou j'ai six fois le 5-fu prend f3
les noirs ont réussi à disloquer la
structure blanche est installé à long
terme le cavalier en f4 et les noirs
vous allez le voir on va avancer
quelques coups d'alger un tour g8 dame
j'ai trois cavaliers f6 il va ramener
l'autre cavaliers vers des cinq tours h
un tour g6 ces trois cavaliers de bons
propose les changes des dan mais quelque
part l'imposent parce que sinon
reprendrait la perte de foot donc dame
prend prise fouet trois cavaliers f4
fous ces deux tours j'ai cette fois
parce que la tour est attaqué on repart
et on voit que les cavaliers vont venir
en aide si ce des 5 et les blancs vont
avoir beaucoup de mal à avancer parce
que ces cavaliers sont sont juste des
monstres un ils sont sur deux bonnes
cases jouer ces quatre ça peut être une
idée on va toujours avoir un peur
d'avoir cavaliers 7 le quai qui peut
revenir vers f5 et ce pion des quatre
qui peut se retrouver faible et l'autre
cavagnan f4 même si on fait ces quatre
admettons à manlay peut-être car il
prend 2,3 en plus ce qui est
problématique avec le cavalier qui vient
en g2 mais quand bien même on devait
ronde devrait revenir en 7 et qui aurait
fait preuve 46.94 même ça ce serait pas
super grave parce que le pion des 4 il
va falloir le surveiller pour toujours
dès que le fou par de la diagonale il ya
du cavalier f5 et à la tour qui peut
rentrer en g2 même ça ça fait pas
vraiment peur au noir et sur un coup
comme tour h4 ici on pourrait jouer le 5
déjà pions prend c'est juste pour
illustrer un tour prend d un fou prend d
un tour g1 les noires s'activent roi ces
deux cavaliers g6 et on
on commence à toute attaque et et vous
voyez le jeu de pièces noir et très
rapidement actif donc difficile avec les
blancs de percer et ça peut être très
dangereux les noirs sont en position de
contre par contre les noirs ont pas
vraiment de plan ils veulent juste
rester comme ça et plus bouger ils ont
ils ont un plan qu'on va voir mais c'est
pas forcément un plan super offensif
food et 2 il joue b5 ici pour gagner à
la case c4 et éviter les c4 tour dh un
tour des g8 bon il est vite si la
tourache sept tours à schwyz
ça permet de se protéger la tour
pourquoi pas fou eu qu'à 3 des 6 6e
place roy c2 qui avait libéré six veut
rentrer en c 4 baies 3 à 5 il veut à 4
tours h 7 à 4 donc planterez thématique
là encore d'hikaru pour se gagner la
case c4 et augmenté la pression est
finalement peut-être un jour réussir à
s'en prendre à ce pion à parce qu'après
b prend il joue cavalier prend avec
l'idée de faire cavalier b6 et cavaliers
un retour c4 pour s'en prendre aux pions
à trois avec une tour qui peut revenir
en 8es donc attaqué fortement ce pion à
3 mais ici à l'iccn qu'on va très bien
réagir il va jouer ces 4 alors ici il y
aurait des variantes avec f5 qui
mènerait à l'égalité direct mais on va
regarder la partie
le truc c'est qu'on aimerait bien faire
qui avait b6 juste pour dire mais sur
pions bob avec l'idée sur fion prend
pions prend key c4 et tout attaquer mais
ici à ses 5
donc on peut pas jouer le coup qu'on
aura le plus envie de jouer dont il fait
dépenser 4 et tout l'idée d'alexei and
co ici c'est d'avoir donné le pion pour
se créer un pion passé à à qui va être
intéressant puisqu'on a un déséquilibre
matériel fou à perdre fou donc pièce
longue portée contre pierre père de
cavaliers pièce courte portée et donc on
veut élargir le conflit et que ce pion à
force un cavalier à rester tout du moins
cavalière à rester au contrôle de ce
pion et après jouer avec les foules le
voile à l'écartement avec le jeu sur
deux elle donc intéressant ici les
blancs jouent les foules et quatre rois
17 tours pranger cette tour pranger
cette tour h 8
donc il veut jouer tour à 8 et venir
aider son pion à est ici pour les noirs
il fallait jouer g4 et créer du contre
je
à l'est le roi avec une position
compliquée et intéressante à jouer des
deux côtés mais dans la partie la fée f5
alors je sais pas s'il a vu après tours
à huit qui aurait tour à sept pour faire
l'enfilade tout du moins donc il a deux
choses attaqué il à la tour et le
cavalier il a pris en quatre tours à 7,3
huit tours angers 7 pions pour un f3 et
tours angers 5 cavaliers detroit dont tu
vas voir échange des pions f
et on va juste avant ces deux trois
coups pour arriver à la position
résultante
après tout cette phase tactique les
blancs ont un avantage cependant en
blitz ça reste une position très
équilibré surtout qu'au moment de cette
partie au 50e coup il ne reste que
quelques secondes aux deux joueurs on
joue sur le plus une seconde de rajouts
et je dois dire que les cavaliers du
coup même si on est moins bien puisque
le pion à et dangereux etc
ah les cavaliers représente un tel un
tel potentiel de fourchette que c'est
difficile de savoir en réalité d'un
point de vue pratique avec peu de temps
qui qui est vraiment mieux et qui jouent
vraiment pour le gain avec les blancs on
aurait le choix de pouvoir se dire ok je
fais nul je fais rien et ça a fait un
nul c'est vrai mais bon on est quand
même tenté de jouer pour la gagner et
dès qu'on va tenter de la gagner on va
risquer de la perdre
donc on va dire que en tenant en compte
la cadence la position est équilibrée
sinon en partie longue évidemment avec
beaucoup de temps sur la pendule c'est
les blancs qui vont presser et peut-être
la gagner on va avancer un petit peu ça
va bouger à gauche à droite il va y
avoir des pièges tenté par hikaru qui
vont finalement marché alors juste on va
avancer donc les blancs qui ont gagné un
pion qui envoie le pion à maintenant
juste pour montrer l'ordinateur il
réussit à gagner en faisant genre ici
tour six cavaliers avec 5 à 6 ils
sacrifient le pion tour prend du coup il
coupe le roi et il va réussir à gagner
un cavalier donc là il menacé le pion
ses cadres dont cavaliere le 3 pour le
défendre
il va faire fou à 5 il va réussir
petit à petit à mettre les blancs en
danger les noirs en danger on peut pas
faire cavalier aussi s'il ya des tours 5
donc cavaliers detroit admettons pour
attaquer la tour et l'ordinateur
juste pour montrer la position finale
parce que c'est un peu ce qui est
intéressant
il va réussir in fine et a attaqué le
cavalier en 3 qui défend le pion en
mettant
sous pression le cavalier des cinq et il
va donc de manière très précise gagné la
partie
mais bon pas pour un être humain c'est
hyper dur c'est hyper précis faut éviter
10000 fourchette est bien bien faire les
choses c'est très dur dans la partie
finalement il va se faire contre piégé
entre guillemets parce que là il ya déjà
menace cavaliers d un fourchette donc il
faut et on peut pas bouger le roi parce
que les cas sont obstruées donc il faut
bouger le fou ces trois échecs français
trois cavaliers d un roi b3 qui est
français trois héros apprend à 5
et ici la position est nul alors avec
les blancs peut pas se permettre de
faire tourner ses huit tours prend ses
six parce que tant qu' un pion en vie
sur l'échiquier deux cavaliers contre un
roi gagne parce qu'au moment où on en
fermera le roi normalement roi de
cavaliers contre roye ça gagne pas parce
qu'il ya des pâtes mais là comme ya le
pion des quatre ans vit il y aura pas de
pâte a cependant il n'y a aucun danger
parce que dès que les noirs gagne gagne
le pion d46 y arrive ce qui n'est pas
gagné
on pourra sacrifier la tour contre le
pion c6 et faire nul immédiatement ici
après tour b 1 il a raté cavaliers des
deux échecs avec avec les noirs mais bon
il a joué à cavalier b6 roi des trois
quarts il est des six tours c1 et a
finalement ils ont fait nul la bonne
technique c'est d'éloigner la tour 1
voyez quand il est venu en bien il
aurait pu se prendre une fourchette la
bonne technique c'est de mettre la tour
très loin du roi pour être sûr qu'ils
aient plus de fourchette est là la
partie un petit peu continuer mais
évidemment il ne peut rien se passer
alors finalement il a sacrifié pour
faire nul mais il pouvait rien se passer
j'espère que la partie vous a plu si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à mettre un
petit pouce bleus et on se retrouve très
bientôt
ciao ciao
[Musique]